Jan Makowski has been growing grapes for
10 years his Oxfordshire Vines are
thriving but he's worried changes to the
rules will cause producers problems I
think it could turn out to be a
double-edged sword yes uh my advice to
any politician would be be careful what
you wish for if you liberalize the
market and throw away the rules without
introducing other safeguards then uh
there are always going to be on
scrupulous players who will knock out
some cheap plonk at the bottom end and
that that could tarnish our image much
of the UK's wine industry is still
regulated by EU rules the government
wants to lose these laws and says this
could be
by 118 million pounds at the moment
things like wine they're governed by 400
pages of regulations we think a lot of
that can be stripped away and make sure
that frankly this should produce uh
potentially up to 50 pence off the cost
of a bottle of wine
that producers like Yan say prices won't
change for high-end English wines there
is a really important difference between
English wines and British wines English
wines use grapes grown here and the wine
has to be made here whereas British
wines can use grapes from anywhere
around the world they're the wines
they're set to benefit from these
changes changes which would come under
the controversial retained EU law Bill
legislation to determine which EU laws
are replaced or kept but some say there
are bigger issues to address than wine
industry rules it's not an uncoinc
Dental that we the government having
walked back their plans on the retained
EU law Bill to scrap all of this EU law
is finding some areas where it feels it
can present improvements and certainly
um uh what the changes around wine look
pretty small compared to what was
originally proposed to drop all EU laws
English wines now have a global
reputation producers say brexits made
life harder creating labor shortages and
complicating exports but the industry is
still growing
with or without EU rules Laura bundock
Sky News